this talented man has been everybody
from Tom Tom Hagen to the Great Santini
she's been a member of famous families
from the Prizzi's to the Addamses and of
course her own please welcome Academy
Award winners Robert Duvall and Angelica
Houston
ask any producer director actor or
writer especially a writer a truly good
screenplay is very hard to come by
either on paper in a word processor or
writers mind it is an art that demands
imagery and mobility and wit and passion
and when they all come together a
screenplay is a thing of beauty
here here the lady knows wherever she
speaks and the pictures nominated for
the Best Original Screenplay this year
are
John Singleton four boys in the hood
James Toback for Bugsy Richard
LaGravenese a for the Fisher King
Lawrence and make a stand for Grand
Canyon and Callie Khouri for Thelma and
Louise
and the Oscar goes to Callie Khouri
hi well for everybody that wanted to see
a happy ending for Thelma in the waves
to me this is it I have a lot of people
I want to thank so I'll get started
Ridley I couldn't thank you in 45 years
much less 45 seconds so I won't try now
Gina and Susan I think you've made the
world a better place so for those
performances I love you
I want to thank my husband who helped me
so much in ways that I could never tell
him and it wasn't by being like Darrell
he wasn't he wasn't the model for any of
the characters in fact my brother was
I'm just kidding I really want to thank
my mother who taught me everything about
love and loyalty that a girl could ever
need to know and all my friends and
family thank you thanks